Pengedaran kuantum Krylov atau KQD secara ringkas merujuk kepada menyelesaikan masalah nilai matriks
dengan memproyekkan matriks ke subruang yang disediakan pada komputer kuantum konsisten dengan kaedah Krylov iaitu
pendekatan yang kukuh daripada aljabar linear klasik. Sepanjang video ini kita akan terokai apa yang membuat kaedah Krylov berguna
dan bagaimana serta bila untuk laksanakannya pada komputer kuantum.
Jadi apa itu kaedah Krylov? Andaikan kita ada matriks H berkaitan dengan usaha saintifik atau perniagaan dengan n baris dan n
lajur. Kita berminat dengan nilai eigen terendah e 0 dan vektor eigen yang sepadan saiz 0. Jom tentukan
vektor awal v yang mungkin dimotivasikan oleh struktur h atau mungkin sepenuhnya rawak. Subruang Krylov
berperingkat r yang kita tulis k r dijana dengan bertindak dengan h pada
vektor awal r tolak satu kali menambah hasil setiap tindakan h seterusnya
kepada set vektor rentang iaitu kr ialah ruang yang direntangi oleh vektor v
hv h kuasa dua dan seterusnya. Vektor-vektor ini umumnya tidak akan ortogon.
Secara klasik, kita sering jalankan proses ortogonanisasi hampir seperti prosedur Graham Schmidt. Kau mulakan
dengan menormalkan vektor awal V dan panggil hasilnya V 0. Kemudian untuk vektor seterusnya HV, kau tolak unjurannya ke atas V 0 untuk jadikan kedua-dua vektor ortogon. Kau kemudian normalkan hasilnya. Kau teruskan seperti ini,
bertindak lagi dengan H dan jadikan hasilnya ortogon kepada semua vektor yang telah ditambah sebelum ini sehingga kau dah bina R
vektor yang dinormalisasiortogon diperlukan untuk merentangi subruang Krylov berdimensi R kau.
Sebaik kau ada subruang ini, kau projek matriks kau ke dalamnya dan diagonalkan matriks yang diprojek yang lebih kecil. Ada
kehalusan dan perluasan, tapi itulah kaedah Krylov pada tahap paling mudahnya.
Untuk faham lebih baik cara ini berfungsi, jom tengok contoh trivial. Kalau H ialah matriks ini dan V dipilih sebagai
vektor ini, maka kita akan mulakan dengan menormalkan V. Untuk jana vektor kedua dalam subruang Krylov, kita bertindak
sekali dengan H pada vektor awal kita dan kemudian jadikan keputusan tu ortogon kepada V 0.
Sedikit algebra menghasilkan ini untuk V1.
Ini tak berguna untuk matriks sekecil ini dan biasanya kita tak berhenti pada dimensi Krylov dua. Tapi kalau kita
nak projek H ke ruang Krylov baru K2, kita akan buat ini menggunakan matriks V
yang ada vektor Krylov untuk setiap lajur dan konjugat transposnya yang ada vektor Krylov untuk baris. Kita kemudian akan
dapatkan matriks ini.
Matriks ini secara teknikalnya berdimensi lebih rendah daripada asal kita. Jelas, pengurangan ini tak berguna pada
skala ini. Kaedah ini bertujuan untuk kurangkan matriks dengan beribu-ribu atau bahkan berjuta-juta baris dan lajur
kepada sekadar beberapa. Jadi kenapa kaedah Krylov berguna? Rupanya preskripsi mudah
tindakan operator ini sering menjadi cara paling cekap untuk mendekati keadaan nilai terendah atau keadaan asas matriks
operator. Jom jadikan ini sedikit lebih eksplisit walaupun kita akan tinggalkan bukti penuh kepada teks yang mengiringi. Kita ingin
selesaikan masalah berbentuk h yang bertindak pada vektor x memberi kita pemalar kali vektor x. Jom mulakan dengan
tekaan vektor eigen kita x0. Ini hanya penyelesaian anggaran. Ia ada ralat yang kita panggil e 0. Sekarang kita nak
buat kemaskini tekaan ini yang kita panggil x1 yang kita harap meningkatkan anggaran kita. Kita boleh nyatakan ini sebagai
x0 asal ditambah beberapa pembetulan p 0 yang masih belum ditentukan. Kita boleh
ulangi proses ini secara berulang menambah lebih banyak vektor pembetulan pi.
Tentulah kita nak ralat kita dikurangkan tapi ia bukan hanya keadaan yang kita ambil berat. Kita juga ambil berat tentang
tindakan h pada keadaan tu. Jadi kuantiti yang betul-betul nak kita minimumkan ialah norma h bagi ralat ini atau norma
tindakan h pada ralat ini.
Sekarang kita nampak ini ialah ungkapan yang melibatkan p 0 dan kita boleh tanya diri kita sendiri pilihan p apa yang minimumkan
norma h ralat ini paling cekap. Dari ruang mana patut kita pilih pembetulan? Di bawah syarat
tertentu seperti bila h simetri dan positif tertentu, memilih r pembetulan pertama daripada dalam kr
ternyata optimum. Dalam istilah yang lebih mudah, kita perlukan beberapa cara untuk menyediakan subruang yang bagus yang boleh kita
projek Hamiltonian kita. Dan dalam banyak kes, subruang Krylov ialah ruang yang direntangi oleh vektor-vektor
pembetulan paling cekap kepada tekaan awal kita.
Untuk bukti sebenar, lihat teks yang mengiringi video ini.
Semua yang kita huraikan setakat ini boleh dilakukan secara klasik. Jadi, bagaimana dan bila kita guna komputer kuantum?
Untuk matriks yang sangat besar, kaedah Krylov boleh memerlukan masa pengiraan yang lama dan jumlah memori yang besar. Masa
yang diperlukan untuk operasi matriks H pada V berskala seperti N kuasa dua dalam kes terburuk.
Dan ini dilakukan untuk setiap vektor yang kita nak dalam subruang kita. Dimensi subruang R biasanya bukan pecahan yang signifikan
daripada N dan sering berskala seperti log N. Jadi menjana semua vektor berskala
seperti tertib N^2 log N.
Walaupun ada langkah lain seperti ortogonalisasi, ini adalah skala dominan untuk diingat.
Pengkomputeran kuantum membolehkan kita ubah atribut masalah apa yang menentukan skala masa dan sumber
yang diperlukan. Bukannya bergantung pada saiz matriks n sepanjang masa, kita akan lihat perkara seperti bilangan shots dan
bilangan sebutan Pauli tidak-penukar yang membentuk Hamiltonian.
Jom terokai cara ini berfungsi.
Ingat bahawa operator yang melakukan evolusi masa keadaan kuantum ialah eksponen iH dibahagi h bar. Dan ia
sangat biasa, terutama dalam pengkomputeran kuantum, untuk tinggalkan h bar daripada notasi.
Satu cara untuk faham dan bahkan realisasikan fungsi eksponen sedemikian bagi operator ialah dengan melihat
pengembangan siri Fourier. Perhatikan bahawa operasi ini yang bertindak pada beberapa vektor awal V menghasilkan jumlah sebutan
dengan kuasa H yang meningkat yang diterapkan pada keadaan awal. Nampaknya kita boleh buat subruang Krylov kita dengan evolusi masa
tekaan keadaan awal kita. Dan itu hampir betul. Kaitan adalah dalam
merealisasikan evolusi masa pada komputer kuantum sebenar. Banyak sebutan dalam Hamiltonian tak akan bertukar dengan
satu sama lain. Jadi sementara beberapa operator eksponen mudah seperti e kepada negatif i z sepadan dengan
circuit mudah Hamiltonian umum tidak dan kerana ia mengandungi sebutan tidak-penukar
kita tak boleh sekadar uraikan eksponen kepada hasil darab yang mudah cara kita boleh dengan nombor. Jadi
ini tidak trivial tapi ini ialah proses yang dikaji dengan baik dalam pengkomputeran kuantum. Kita jalankan evolusi masa
pada komputer kuantum menggunakan proses yang dipanggil trotterisasi yang dengan sendirinya merupakan topik yang kaya. Tapi pada tahap yang sangat tinggi
dengan memecahkan evolusi masa kepada langkah-langkah kecil katakan M langkah kita hadkan kesan ketidak-penukaran
sebutan. Mari kita panggil subruang Krylov berperingkat r yang kita jana dalam konteks klasik menggunakan kuasa h
terus sebagai subruang Krylov kuasa kpr.
Sekarang kita jana ruang yang serupa menggunakan operator evolusi masa unitari u yang diberikan oleh eksponen iht.
Kita akan rujuk ini sebagai ruang Krylov unitari kur.
Subruang Krylov kuasa kpr yang kita guna secara klasik tak boleh dijana terus pada komputer kuantum kerana h
bukan operator unitari. Menggunakan subruang Krylov unitari boleh ditunjukkan memberi jaminan penumpuan yang serupa
seperti subruang Krylov kuasa.
Khususnya, ralat keadaan asas menumpu dengan cekap asalkan keadaan awal V ada pertindihan dengan
keadaan asas sebenar yang tidak memudar secara eksponen dan asalkan ada jurang yang mencukupi antara nilai eigen
keadaan. Di sini kuasa u menjadi langkah masa yang berbeza. Kuasa ke-k bagi u adalah melangkah
ke hadapan sebanyak masa k * dt.
Kita boleh labelkan elemen subruang yang dievolusi masa untuk jumlah masa kdt sebagai s sub k. Kita boleh projek
Hamiltonian H kita ke subruang Krylov unitari kur. Dengan kata lain, kita
kira setiap elemen matriks h dalam asas kur. Kita akan rujuk ini
sebagai matriks yang diprojek h tilde. Elemen matriks H tilde diberikan oleh nilai jangkaan ini yang boleh
dianggar menggunakan komputer kuantum.
Ingat bahawa H boleh ditulis sebagai jumlah operator Pauli pada qubit yang berbeza dan tidak semua operator Pauli
boleh diukur serentak. Kita boleh susun sebutan Pauli kepada kumpulan sebutan penukar dan ukur kesemua
sekali gus. Tapi kita mungkin perlukan banyak kumpulan sedemikian untuk meliputi semua sebutan. Jadi bilangan kumpulan penukar yang berbeza yang
sebutan boleh dibahagikan kepada ngcp jadi penting. Kalau kita guna subruang Krylov unitari berdimensi r
matriks yang terhasil akan berdimensi r * r. Kalau r jauh lebih kecil daripada n maka kita dah
buat kemajuan yang berguna dan biasanya r jauh lebih kecil daripada 100 bermakna kita boleh diagonalkan ini dengan mudah pada komputer klasik
Tapi ingat bahawa s n dan s m umumnya tidak akan ortogon. Ia
kadang-kadang mungkin untuk diagonalkan matriks dalam asas yang tidak ortogon. Tapi ada sebab berangka dan fizikal
untuk menukar dahulu kepada asas ortogon. Oleh itu kita selesaikan masalah nilai eigen teritlak menggunakan matriks Gram s.
Elemen mn matriks Gram diberikan oleh hasil darab dalam s m pada cn.
Kedua-dua elemen H tilde dan S dikira menggunakan ujian Hadamard.
Masalah nilai eigen teritlak kemudiannya menjadi ini.
Seperti yang dinyatakan di atas, dimensi subruang Krylov unitari R adalah lebih kecil secara eksponen daripada dimensi matriks asal
kita N. Jadi masalah nilai ini mudah diselesaikan secara klasik.
Untuk merumuskan, kita mulakan dengan keadaan rujukan, kemudian evolusikannya untuk tempoh masa yang berbeza untuk jana
subruang Krylov unitari. Kita projek Hamiltonian kita ke subruang tu dan kita juga anggar pertindihan
vektor subruang. Akhirnya, kita selesaikan masalah nilai teritlak berdimensi rendah secara klasik. Jom bandingkan apa
yang menentukan kos pengiraan menggunakan teknik Krylov secara klasik dan mekanikal kuantum. Kita sketsa ini
sudah untuk versi klasik dan tiada analogi sempurna antara pendekatan klasik dan kuantum untuk semua langkah. Tapi jadual ini mengumpulkan beberapa
skala langkah yang berbeza untuk pertimbangan. Ingat bahawa Hamiltonian umumnya ada sebutan yang tidak boleh diukur serentak kerana ia
tidak bertukar. Kita susun sebutan dalam Hamiltonian kepada kumpulan operator Pauli penukar yang boleh semua diukur serentak dan kita mungkin perlukan banyak
kumpulan sedemikian untuk ambil kira semua sebutan yang tidak bertukar. Untuk bina H tilde pada komputer kuantum memerlukan
pengukuran berasingan bagi setiap kumpulan rentetan Pauli penukar dalam Hamiltonian. Dan setiap daripada itu memerlukan banyak shots. Kita mesti buat ini untuk R
kuasa dua elemen matriks yang berbeza sepadan dengan R kuasa dua kombinasi faktor evolusi masa yang berbeza. Ada
kadang-kadang cara untuk kurangkan ini. Tapi dalam rawatan kasar ini, masa yang diperlukan untuk ini berskala lebih kurang seperti
bilangan shots kali bilangan kumpulan sebutan Pauli penukar kali r kuasa dua.
Elemen s mesti dianggar yang berskala seperti bilangan shots
per kubus. Kita nampak bahawa pengedaran kuantum Krylov mungkin berguna dalam kes di mana bilangan kumpulan Pauli penukar
dalam Hamiltonian agak kecil.
Kebergantungan skala ini mencadangkan beberapa aplikasi di mana kaedah Krylov boleh berguna dan yang lain di mana ia mungkin
tidak. Beberapa Hamiltonian mempunyai kerumitan tinggi bila dipetakan kepada qubit melibatkan banyak rentetan Pauli tidak-penukar
yang tidak mudah dibahagikan kepada beberapa kumpulan penukar.
Ini sering berlaku untuk masalah kimia kuantum. Contohnya, kerumitan ini menghadirkan dua cabaran utama untuk
komputer kuantum jangka dekat. Pertama, anggaran setiap elemen H tilde menjadi mahal secara pengiraan disebabkan
bilangan sebutan yang besar. Kedua, circuit Trotter yang diperlukan menjadi sangat dalam. Kedua-dua perkara ini
akan kurang bermasalah bila komputer kuantum mencapai toleransi kesalahan, tapi ia mesti dipertimbangkan dalam jangka dekat. Malah sistem dengan pemetaan yang lebih mudah
berbanding kimia kuantum mungkin mengalami halangan yang sama kalau Hamiltonian ada terlalu banyak sebutan tidak-penukar
berbanding kimia kuantum mungkin mengalami halangan yang sama kalau Hamiltonian ada terlalu banyak sebutan tidak-penukar.
Kaedah Krylov paling berguna di mana Hamiltonian boleh dibahagikan kepada beberapa kumpulan Pauli penukar yang agak sedikit
dan di mana H mudah dilaksanakan dalam circuit Trotter. Kedua-dua syarat ini dipenuhi. Contohnya,
untuk banyak model kekisi yang menarik dalam fizik, KQD amat berguna kalau sangat sedikit yang diketahui tentang
keadaan asas. Ini berpunca daripada jaminan penumpuan yang sedia ada dan kebolehgunaannya dalam senario di mana
kaedah alternatif tidak dapat digunakan disebabkan pengetahuan keadaan asas yang tidak mencukupi.
Walaupun KQD adalah alat yang berkuasa, aspek protokol yang memakan masa, terutamanya anggaran setiap
elemen Hamiltonian yang diprojek dan pertindihan keadaan Krylov, merupakan peluang untuk penambahbaikan. Satu
pendekatan alternatif melibatkan menganggar keadaan Krylov menggunakan circuit Trotter, kemudian mensampel
keadaan yang dianggar untuk dapatkan unjuran ke asas pengiraan dan kemudian memproyeksikan h ke subruang
yang direntangi oleh keadaan asas pengiraan ini.
Dalam kes di mana ia boleh digunakan, metodologi yang dikenali sebagai pengedaran kuantum Krylov berasaskan pensampelan SKQD
berpotensi menawarkan pengurangan yang ketara dalam keperluan masa dan sumber berbanding KQD tradisional.
Integrasi teknik subruang Krylov dengan kaedah pensampelan dalam SKQD mewakili sempadan yang menarik dalam
algoritma kuantum.